optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking when I also supposed to a
question now I see I must - etic
organism living tissue over metal
endoskeleton this episode is brought to
you by Vimeo Pro which is the ideal
video hosting platform for entrepreneurs
and in fact a bunch of my startups
already use Vimeo Pro including
wealthfront who uses it to explain how
wealthfront works TaskRabbit uses it to
tell their company's story and there are
many other names you would recognize
among their customers
Airbnb Etsy etc why do they use it well
Vimeo Pro provides enterprise level
video hosting for a fraction of the
usual cost features include gorgeous
high quality playback with no ads up to
20 gigabytes of video storage every week
unlimited plays and views and a fully
customizable video player which can
include your logo custom outro etc you
also get VIP support and you get all of
this for just $1.99 per year that's $17
a month with no complicated bandwidth
calculations or hidden fees and you can
try it risk-free for 30 days so check it
out Vimeo comm forward slash business
that's VI m EO com forward slash
business and use promo code Tim to get
25% off that's a special discount just
for you guys so check it out Vimeo com
forward slash business promo code Tim
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealthfront is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront com forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on the show it's because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant
out of my own money at least for me in
the team and the company itself so I am
an investor and hope to soon use it as a
client now back to the recommendation as
a Tim Ferriss show listener
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if
you decide to open an account but just
start with seeing the portfolio that
they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront comm forward slash Tim it's
fast it's free there's no downside that
I can think of now I do have to read a
mandatory disclaimer wealthfront Inc is
an SEC registered investment advisor
investing in securities involves risks
and there's the possibility of losing
money past performance is no guarantee
of future results please visit wealth
front comm to read their full disclosure
so check it out guys this is one of the
hottest most innovative companies coming
out of Silicon Valley and they're
killing it they've become massively
popular just take a look see what
portfolio they would create for you and
you can use that information however you
want wealthfront comm forward slash tim
hello my friends you muscular little
oompa-loompas welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show my name is Tim
Ferriss and my job is to deconstruct
world class performers people who are
the best at what they do and to tease
out the habit routines findings that you
can apply to your own life whether they
are people like Arnold Schwarzenegger
chess prodigies like Josh Waitzkin
directors like Jon Favreau or Robert
Rodriguez and hedge fund managers
military strategists everyone in between
today we have a researcher dr. Brene
brown and you can say hi to her on
twitter at Brene brown is a research
professor at the University of Houston
Graduate School of Social Work and her
2010 TEDx talk the power of
vulnerability has more than 20 million
views it is one of the top 5 most viewed
TED talks in the world which is very
hard to pull off she has other talks
with millions and millions of views so
once you're lucky twice you're good she
is very good she has spent the past 13
years studying vulnerability courage
worthiness and shame all my favorites
Brene is the author of two number one
New York Times bestsellers daring
greatly and the gifts of imperfection
her brand-new book is tied
old rising strong and in it she writes
if we are brave enough often enough we
will fall this is a book about what it
takes to get back up and she interviews
some very interesting folks top
performers in the corporate world
startup world military world and gathers
data to support the recommendations and
conclusions in these books so I have a
copy of rising strong and encourage you
to check it out she's also the founder
and CEO for the daring way which is an
organization that brings her work to
organizations schools communities and
families and without further ado I want
to let you enjoy this wide-ranging
conversation that touches on some
sensitive topics you might say with dr.
Brene brown Rene welcome to the show
thank you I'm excited to talk to you and
my fans are excited to hear all of your
wisdom and dig into your research uh and
I suppose we could we could start with
some context for those people who are
not familiar with your work when you are
asked the question what do you do how do
you answer that it really actually had
two answers I one if I want to keep
talking and one if I don't so if I don't
want to keep talking I usually will just
say I'm a shame researcher and that
scares people and then they usually go
on they usually say so what do you think
about the Texans this season or
something and then if I'm in a normal
conversation I'll say that I study
vulnerability and courage shame and
worthiness and that's been kind of
terrible isn't it but I do that I I
don't think it's terrible I think that
you can do kind of a reverse George
Costanza when you don't want to talk to
someone if you're trapped on a plane or
something so so instead of saying you
know picking the most interesting thing
to get them to admire you and say you're
an architect you can be like oh yes no
I'm a oh you could bring up something
extremely awkward right like I you know
I I research uh you know off-color sex
trafficking or something in there
depending on who you're sitting next to
suppose it could be a good character
check right
totally it's a total character chef
because if they launch in after they
hear I study shame then that kind of
bites me on the ass a little bit but it
works pretty well you're like you're not
following the script pal you're you're
officer said so speaking of script and I
am not the only one who's been impressed
with your presenting ability but it
seems like one of the ways that you
really hit the mainstream map was
through Ted and specifically I guess it
would have been the the power of
vulnerability although that that has
more than 21 million views now and some
of your other presentations are more
than 5 million views so certainly you
know once you're lucky twice you're good
you're good at this
could you give people an overview of the
components that make a hit speech or TED
talk because you're clearly good at it
it's not a one-hit wonder how did the
power vulnerability
come to be how did you decide on the on
that on the content and rehearse it and
so on just the the Genesis story I think
would be very interesting um yeah I'd
love to share because it's been a huge
learning for me so the TEDx talk was
kind of a combination of an accident and
an experiment the curators of TEDx
Houston asked me to open their first
event and they called and they were
really excited and I asked I said sure
I'd love to I was really excited and
they Javier padule is the curator and I
said what do you want me to talk about
and you know when you study things like
shame and vulnerability people can get
very prescriptive about what they want
you to say and what they don't want you
to say it really has no bearing actually
on what I do say but they like to think
in the beginning that they're going to
control some of that and so I said you
know do you have any i thoughts and his
answer was be awesome have fun and the
day before the yeah which is you would
think it's liberating and but it's also
kind of terrifying right and so
blessing in the curse of no constraints
exactly exactly and so I was on a flight
home the night before a long flight with
my husband and kids and I looked at
Steven I was like I think I'm gonna
experiment tomorrow and my husband
looked at me and he said that sounds
like a terrible idea and I said yeah and
I said no I think I'm going to actually
be really vulnerable while I'm talking
about vulnerability and he said yeah
again not sure that's a great idea so I
went to the Ted event and I experimented
I really kind of put myself out there I
talked about my own breakdown spiritual
whitening I talked about having to go to
therapy and how much I really hated that
I kind of thought it was [ __ ] like I
had to do it and I really put myself out
there I remember driving home and
thinking I will never do that again
I mean I literally had I literally had
what I thought was one of the worst
vulnerability hangovers of my career and
I was so grateful you know I have to
tell you I'm so grateful that there were
only 500 people there and that it was
recorded at University of Houston where
I've taught for 20 years so most people
kind of like oh yeah that's Brunei I
don't have any memory of that being
recorded and I and I'm pretty I'm pretty
sure maybe the universe just aligned
didn't thought you know let's not let
her know that this is being recorded so
when it came out on the TEDx you know on
the TEDx site I was pretty mortified and
Steve Cena seems like no one's going to
watch it don't worry and then several
months later Chris Anderson called and
said hey we're we don't usually put the
TEDx talks at but we really love your
chocolate want to product I think the
conversation like this which is an
interesting form of leadership I think I
said no I'm flattered but no thank you
and he said I think December 23rd will
be great and then that was that and so
it went up on December 23rd and against
II was like don't worry Brene I don't
think that any people are not going to
see it and it went like one two
1 million 1 million 1 3 million a nice
like oh and so if I look back so my
learning my takeaway from that
experience was this if I'm not a little
bit nauseous when I'm done I probably
did not show up like I should have shown
up that's great that's that's that's
that Echo's advice from I believe it's
Neil Gaiman in the commencement speech
make good art where you talked about you
know when you feel like you're walking
down the street naked and extremely
uncomfortable maybe you're starting to
get it right I'm sorry I'm paraphrasing
of course but that's a that's a really
good that's a really good point how did
you I mean your delivery was so spot-on
how did you rehearse or did you I mean
maybe you're just maybe that is a
language that you're naturally fluent in
presentation that is but how did you
prep for it I don't rehearse at all in
fact rehearsing is really so when I
rehearse in the traditional way we think
about rehearsing it's about what I'm
going to say and what I'm going to say
it and how I'm going to say it and so if
I do that what ends up happening I've
tried a couple times I get so like
prefrontal cortex I get so wrapped up
and Oh wasn't I supposed to pause here
and wasn't I supposed to do this there
that I am NOT I'm not connecting and so
for me it is use images as the Ark
understand what image every image means
to me and what I want to wrap around
that image and then require that the
house lights are on so I can see
people's faces that's a good rule that's
a really good rule yeah so that thing
where they're you know and I really
really allow any of my presentations to
be videotaped very very rarely because
one if they're taping you you have to be
super hot under the lights and the
has to be dark and then it's performance
not connection for me and then secondly
I don't feel like it's anyone's business
what happens between me and an audience
at any given moment mm-hmm I mean I just
really feel like that's that's a moment
yeah and I think that comes I mean I'm
I'm speculating here but from a lot of
experience teaching right being in in
front of students as opposed to viewing
yourself as being in front of an
audience which which I think enables a
very different relationship with the
people you're trying to communicate to
or communicate with and to provide
perhaps a little bit of connective
tissue for people who are curious about
your research
you mentioned vulnerability mentioned
shame how should we define these terms
just for the purposes of this
conversation and so people can
understand and how did you research them
you know I think the best place to start
when we're talking about kind of what
words mean at least the way I use them
in my work as you really start with
vulnerability and if I think if you can
get your head and heart wrapped about
around vulnerability the others make a
lot more sense so to me I don't know how
you were raised and how the listeners
were raised but I was raised to believe
that vulnerability is weakness
that you wake up in the morning you
armor up you go out into the day you
kick some ass you don't let people see
your emotions you mitigate uncertainty
and risk as much as you can and that's
the way you live and so from the very
earliest stages of my research you know
13 years ago that is not how vulnerable
'ti emerged in the data vulnerability
emerged as not weakness but probably our
best measure of courage so when we asked
people you know what is vulnerability
they would say things like it's the
first date after my divorce it's trying
to get pregnant after my second
miscarriage it's sitting with my wife
who has stage four breast cancer and
making plans for our three year old and
five year old it's
in my own business it's taking my
business public it's getting fired it's
firing someone it's getting promoted
it's missing the promotion and so it
can't became very clear to me early on
that the simplest definition for
vulnerability is really uncertainty risk
and emotional exposure vulnerability is
about the willingness to show up and be
seen when you have zero control over the
outcome and I think if you ask people to
close their eyes and think about the
last time they saw uh someone doing
something truly brave it is very easy to
see how vulnerability underpins all acts
of courage sure and yeah I mean I just
think it's about really it's about
putting yourself out there and which is
increasingly difficult to do in this
very hyper critical unforgiving kind of
media culture and so vulnerability is
showing up and being seen um
courage to me you know I love the word
courage because the root of the word is
kur and the Latin for kur is heart and
when courage first came into the English
language the original definition was to
tell the story of you of who you are
with your whole heart that was an act of
courage so to me courage is really about
choosing what's right over what's easy
practicing your values not just
professing them and choosing to be brave
over being comfortable and these I love
this type of contextual cut Prelude it's
not a pre mood but it's defining because
I think it's so important for any
important conversation and certainly I
think for most conversations to make
sure that the people in the conversation
are talking about the same thing right
yeah
the key to everything right and that
starts with defining very ver and I've
noticed for instance even in my own
relationship something as seemingly
clear as honesty I want you to be honest
say in intimate relationships are
actually can can have a no pun intended
but you know Fifty Shades of Grey right
I mean there are it means something very
different you know is is a mission a lie
or are we talking about a
misrepresentation of truth right and
it's it's it's really critical and I
like your description because your
courage I remember thinking when you
were when you were walking us through
this cus D'Amato who was Mike Tyson's
primary trainer who who who who brought
him to the pinnacle of his success would
tell Mike who was terrified before going
into the ring in the dressing room and
so on
that it you know the hero and the coward
feel the same thing it's how the how
it's how the hero responds that makes
him different and you know the the you
can't be courageous unless you are
exposing yourself to a perceived risk
which by definition makes you vulnerable
even if you're thinking about it in the
very literal kind of physical sense so
the the I'd love to segue to to shame
because I was reading one of your alumni
publications and you can correct this
certainly if it's not accurate but a
quote of yours came up that I thought
was was really insightful and worth
exploring a bit and it said shame hates
to have words wrapped around it if we
talk about it it loses its grip on us
and I was hoping maybe we could you
could elaborate on that and help us to
then understand shame yeah and I think
that that quote is so powerful because
it's so true like I often when I talk
about shame I often like to personify it
and say you know shame is a very
formidable foe you know shame is this in
ten
painful belief or experience that
something is wrong with us that we are
flawed and that we are unworthy of love
and belonging and we all know it
everyone knows that warm wash that comes
over you that makes you feel like you're
not enough we have 50 years of data that
really show us in my mind unquestionably
that the only people who don't
experience shame are people who don't
have a capacity for connection who
people who don't have a capacity for
empathy so if we are capable of having
connection we no shame because shame is
the fear that we're not worthy of
connection and so the thing about shame
that makes it so difficult is it needs
three things to thrive in our lives if
you take a petri dish and you put shame
in a petri dish and you douse it with
secrecy silence and judgment it grows
exponentially it will it will grow into
every corner and crevice of our lives if
you have the same amount of shame in a
petri dish and you douse it with empathy
shame can't survive in but the empathy
is a very hostile environment for shame
and so to understand shame I think what
resonates mostly with people are the two
kind of tapes that shame drives the
first is you're not enough and you can
fill in the blank
you're not thin enough pretty enough
strong enough powerful enough rich
enough from it enough loved enough
awesome enough you know you're not
enough and then if we can somehow get a
handle on that and say you know like
okay I've got you know I have this big
presentation and you got the shame
gremlin and you're either saying you're
not an app you're not smart enough
they're going to be like a hundred MBAs
in that room what do you know about
business you're not enough if you can
wrestle that thing down the other tape
that shame drives is who do you think
you are so it creates this amazing vise
that our self or
gets caught in and then just squeezes s
from both sides and so shame and shame
is really visceral I mean if you if you
just say the word to people people can
feel it no definitely and you mentioned
you to fear of disconnection I mean I
wrote down when I was doing some
research before this call you know being
shunned question mark and I'd love to
ask you because a question that came
from some of my listeners was you know
what is the evolutionary need of shame
or or why did that develop in human
beings and it seems to me like shame can
serve a useful purpose right if you are
ashamed of the fact that you think about
molesting a child that scene that serves
a societal function right so how would I
do that
you would argue no I would argue now
absolutely not okay all right well I'd
love for you to expand on that because
that's that's that's an interesting
viewpoint so could you could you expand
on it so shame I think if you look at
shame from an evolutionary biological
perspective I think it did absolutely
serve a function so Tim you lead the
dinosaur back to the cave it eats my
entire family and my whole clan this is
the second time you've done that so we
are literally going to shun you from our
collective which means you'll be alone
which means death right and so because
you're dangerous I'm just not not unlike
if we see even in the animal world today
some pack animals if there's a sick
animal among them will literally you
know approach it as a group and back it
off a cliff for the sake of the the pack
right so so that makes sense as we've
evolved as we've evolved
neurobiologically as we've evolved shame
becomes a very a profoundly dangerous
tool
for people who have the emotional
understanding that we have so now what
we see is you can change a behavior
sometimes especially with children on a
dime with shame but it's like hitting a
thumbtack with a 500 pound anvil you are
going to crush that thumbtack in the
process of doing that so what we see now
is we see shame highly highly correlated
with addiction depression aggression
violence suicide eating disorders very
highly correlated what we see as the
inverse is we see guilt and shame and
guilt are very different shame is I am a
bad person
guilt is I did something bad so you go
out on Thursday night you get wasted
you're so hungover on Friday you sleep
through your alarm clock you miss a
really important meeting you get to work
late on Friday and your self-talk is
Jesus I'm a loser
I'm an idiot I'm such a loser that shame
if you get to work on Friday same
scenario and your self-talk is dude I
cannot believe I did that that was such
a lame thing to do that was such a
stupid thing to do the difference is
shame is a focus on self guilt is a
focus on behavior people who are very
guilt prone who say you know what I got
a bad grade I'm not a loser but that was
a loser idea to not study and go out
last night they have their relationship
with addiction depression violence
suicide bullying is inverse meaning the
higher the level of guilt the less
likely it is to experience these
outcomes so the most dangerous if you
look at shame and guilt in a criminal
population the most dangerous people
have the highest levels of shame promise
and the lowest levels of Gil
Primus let me because guilt is an older
person does that make sense it makes
perfect sense yeah so guilt is holding
up something we've done against who we
want to be or something we've done
thought about doing or fail to do up
against our values who we want to be
what we think is right and guilt is the
psychological discomfort created by the
cognitive dissonance between our
behavior and who we want to be and it's
healthy and adaptive it makes perfect
sense I was having a conversation with
Josh Waitzkin who's been on this podcast
as well he was the basis for searching
for bobby fisher' so he was known as a
chess prodigy as a child ah he is a
tremendous dad a really amazing parent
as a young boy and he has a very
particular parenting style and he always
focuses on rewarding effort and not
labeling his son smart so for instance
he'll say that was a really good job you
worked really hard you did a B and C
that resulted in D as opposed to wow you
got a great grade you're so smart
because then when the kid gets a bad
grade it's viewed as this it this
unsolvable unfixable personal failing
and it seems to correlate to the
difference between shame ie I am flawed
I'm a broken toy that cannot be fixed
versus guilt like wow I really [ __ ]
that up bad on me but next time I'll do
something different usually and the
other thing is think about this as 16
year old 10 year old you know they get
caught being dishonest with me and I say
you know what you're a liar and you're
grounded when you tell somebody they're
a liar
that's a self-fulfilling prophecy what
what if you're if you're a liar if I'm a
vibrant a brown I'm a liar
what option is there for growth or
change well I am right not only that but
what incentive is there not to lie if
you're branded as such right so when you
talk about the person who is thinking
about committing violence or
on a child do I want that person to be
more ashamed no because I have a feeling
I mean there's there's you know in your
example I guess there's pedophilia which
can be an organic real issue but the
majority of what we see are people who
are so deeply shamed based committing
horrific crimes so look if I thought
shaming people no matter how I mean I
hate to say this but I'll just be honest
if I thought shaming people no matter
how hurtful and painful it is if I
thought that kept people safer I'd be
all for it it just doesn't right right
well it's you know it's interesting
because I've been training a rescue pup
for the last few weeks
brand-new rescue pup and she was at a
kill shelter in South Carolina and
suffered a lot of abuse but really got
into looking at mammalian training and
looking at everything from dolphin
training to polar bear training the dog
training and the fact of the matter is
you know negative reinforcement or
punishment based training doesn't work
that well or at least at the very best
it's very slow compared to a lot of the
positive reinforcement based training
you know whether it's using you know
clickers for conditioning and so on
because you can only reinforce a
behavior that that is that is that has
occurred right and when you it I think
that the the shame just seems to tie to
me in an interesting way to not
understanding what is malleable and what
is not and I'd love to come back to the
I am enough because in your book one of
your several books but the gift of
imperfection one of the best book titles
of all time by the way so well done on
that has been described as the lifelong
journey from what will people think - I
am enough now what I'm so curious to
hear about and then I'll leap forward to
daring greatly and I'll just read this
this quote from which I believe that the
title was was adapted so this is
Theodore Roosevelt there's not the
critic who counts not the man who
points out how straw how the strong man
stumbles or where the doer of Deeds
could have done them better the credit
belongs to the man who is actually in
the arena whose face is marred by dust
and sweat and blood who strives
valiantly who had the best knows in the
end of the triumph of high achievement
and who at worst if he fails at least
fails while daring greatly now what I
have had as an internal conflict for a
very long time and this was brought to
the surface
most noticeably in the last year and a
half through meditation so I practiced
Transcendental Meditation in the
mornings and have friends who practice
the pasta Trane's then all different
types of meditation and these are type a
driven competitive people and we've I've
had the conversation repeatedly the same
conversation with different people about
whether that removes a competitive edge
and the reason being that you decide I
am enough you're content therefore you
do not have discontent driving you to
achieve big things that are for most of
us pretty high on Maslow's hierarchy of
needs right it's like we have shelter we
have food so in reality like in in
almost every capacity we have enough we
are enough so how do you balance the the
the well-being of having a mindset of I
am enough versus the at least with a lot
of my peers and friends in Silicon
Valley the kind of discontent that seems
to drive so many of those people to
accomplish great things so I would go
back to your really important insight
from the beginning of our conversation
about defining terms I'd also go back to
kind of the insights that you're
learning from doing your training with
your rescue pot which is does to me I am
enough I mean I'm a competitive type a
person to which PO doesn't come as a
surprise the oldest of four you know
very ambitious and you know I'm I'm that
person too
in many ways um I think the soul are the
center of my ability to keep putting
myself out there and trying new things
even when I fail and I have had some big
failures I think the soul of my healthy
competitiveness and my ambition is the
belief that I am enough um because I'm
starting and I think what I don't
believe I'm enough I engage in behaviors
not to push myself not to grow and
stretch and learn not to strive for
excellence but to prove to other people
what I can do but when I start from a
place that you know what I'm enough I'm
imperfect I'm afraid
I'm you know super vulnerable but that
does not change the fact that I'm also
brave and worthy of love and belonging
and when I start from that place
I am completely Unleashed so I think one
of the things that's really important to
help kind of define here because I'm not
like you know on the couch binge
watching TV five days a week writing
nasty ass comments on other people's
accomplishments on you know Twitter and
Facebook and saying look [ __ ] you I'm
enough like that's not what I'm talking
about
you know right I'm talking about a
belief of self-worth that I am enough
not based on what I do what I accomplish
what do I you know prove or produce I am
just enough and if you start from that
that's the healthy sinner I think of the
most most of the most awesome
achievements we've seen and I spend a
lot of time in Silicon Valley too and
what I can tell you and I know I would
bet I wish we could have a bet right now
I would bet you a lot of money that if
we listed the names of 10p
which we're not gonna do you could tell
me which of those folks are operating
and the 1010 competitive ambitious Jess
like crazy fighters out there in the
arena and we listed two names you could
tell me the five who are motivated from
a place of being enough but wanting to
strive for excellence and learning and
the five who are trying to fill a hole
and their self-worth and who are
dangerous ya know for sure and I think I
guess the in my mind when I think I'm
just imagining this list of ten people
in my head when I imagine the people who
fall into the less self-destructive
category who have were operating from a
place of I am enough I guess I would in
their cases say that in the if I could
hear their sort of subconscious internal
mantra it would it would in in my mind
it would seem to be and maybe this is
the same thing but uh closer to I am I'm
good or I'm really good but I can be
better not I am flawed uh I need to
impress everyone around me to make them
validate me but the I guess I'm just
struggling with the word enough but I
understand the the point of it and I
think it's this is something that I
struggle with right I mean I'm extremely
personally I'm very hard on myself I
mean I've always sort of been of the
mindset that you know second place is
first loser and extremely competitive
and that has not always been the
healthiest thing for me in all sorts of
different capacities but I don't the
let's let's sort of tackle this from a
slightly different angle so the the
daring greatly the question that I think
is raised in that that book among others
is you know have you dared greatly today
and
please feel free to take this in any
direction because you obviously know
more about your work than I do but how
what is a good way to evaluate that and
do you ask yourself this type of
question on a daily basis do you have
I'll leave it at that I could I could
make this a 12 part question but how
does someone determine if they've dared
greatly and is how often would you
suggest someone kind of check in and ask
themselves that so I think for me
Daren greatly and you know that that
quote from Peter is about I even got
teary eyed while you were reading it you
know it was a life changer for me um it
was right after the TEDx Houston talk
had gone viral I was kind of everywhere
on the internet at that time and you
know everyone for ABC CBS NBC Fox having
impetus were all writing about this who
is this person at the University of
Houston with this TED talk going viral
and as if he could have imagined and all
these online stories had online comments
that Wooper have Gru's like yeah and so
my husband and my therapist were like
don't read the comments and so I read
all the comments one day and yeah I
really I sat down and just read them for
like an hour I think you know if you ask
if you're listening to God give your
listener right now you know if you close
your eyes and think about we all have
the same triggers we all have two or
three things yeah most of us have more
that you can overhear somebody you could
overhear someone saying about you that
would be so painful and so hurtful that
you don't know if you could survive it
most of us have those things and so for
me up until that point you know I those
things really dictated my life I was
like look I'm going to engineer this
career to kind of be small and safe I'm
going to play right under the radar
because I am not willing to put myself
out there and get criticized like I know
is happening and so the problem with
staying small is it's always served up
with resentment and pissed off at us and
because we're not using our gifts we're
not in our power and there's always a
price for that
I and so to me when I read that quote
you know when I looked at the comments
they were things like of course she you
know except or she embraces imperfection
what choice would you have if you look
like her I feel sorry for her husband
and kids more Botox less research you
need to shake lose ten pounds before you
talk about being worthy I mean just like
really shitty hurtful stuff and then I
came on I came upon that I mean like the
next 30 minutes after we know that I
came upon that comment I mean that quote
from Theodore Roosevelt and you know in
that moment what I realized is you know
what I do want to live a brave life I do
want to live in the arena and if you're
going to live in the arena
the only guarantee is you will get your
ass kicked and the second thing is that
Darin greatly is being vulnerable so
when you ask yourself did I dear greatly
today the big question I ask is did I
when I had the opportunity did I choose
courage over comfort you know when
things went sideways between Steve and I
this morning over you know who was going
to pack a lunch for my son did I just go
into the old pattern of rolling my eyes
and walk down the kitchen or did I
choose courage and say I'm sorry I'm
feeling really overwhelmed with the book
launch tomorrow and I'm sorry I really
apologized that was hurtful did I choose
courage or dead she's comfort and so to
me that's the question we asked about
daring greatly and I think you know I
think one of the things that you said 10
really when you're talking about your
friends and this idea being enough one
of the things that really turned my life
upside down
there were four or five things in the
research that have taken me a long time
to get over and get through and one of
them was the difference between healthy
striving or striving for excellence and
perfectionism and I've always been
perfectionistic about my staff and what
I learned in the research was that
perfectionism is very outwardly defined
it's dictated by what will people think
and healthy striving is dictate
our striving for excellence is
internally motivated and so
perfectionism is really I call it the
20-ton shield and I think a lot of we're
talking about those ten people five of
whom work from this place of wholeness
and the other I think what a lot of
times we're talking about is the
difference between perfectionism and
striving for excellence and I think
perfectionism is this 20-ton shield that
we carry around and it's a defense
mechanism classically it just says if I
live perfect love perfect work perfect
and accomplished perfectly I can reduce
or minimize shame blame criticism and
judgment and so we carry this thing
around
I'm thinking it's protecting us but what
it's really doing is keeping us from
being seen and so I think when I ask
myself personally have idea greatly
today sometimes for me it is the
question of was I enough or am I trying
to get everything perfect so that I can
somehow think I'm mitigating criticism
and judgment right well I also find and
I haven't really thought about it in
these terms before but if you look at
say I think it's Barry Schwartz the
paradox of choice where he talks about
maximizers and I think it's satisficers
yeah but if I try to correlate that to
my own experience being I think very
much a perfectionist and that of my my
friends the the people who are
perfectionists very often are so future
focused that the perfection once
achieved as viewed as the trigger that
will sort of solve their guilt shame
discontent oh yeah whereas the the
people who are striving for excellence
excellence are better at celebrating the
little wins accepting the small defeats
and sometimes the large defeats and tend
to be a bit more present state focused
and you mentioned you to vulnerability
and you end the sort of components right
so you facing whether it's an
uncertainty risk and so on
and I've seen it described elsewhere as
you know stopping controlling and
predicting the it seems very much akin
to certain tenets and say stoic
philosophy of which I read a lot
whether it's spark is really us or
Seneca and then there are a lot of
common threads in Buddhism of course
that would talk about how how fruitless
it is and futile it is to try to
eliminate suffering completely because
the we are almost by definition
experiencers of suffering right and
coming to terms with that what which
which thinkers philosophers or schools
of thinking or philosophy most resonate
with the insights you found in in the
data in your research oh my god e all of
the above like I mean it took me it took
me from Marcus Aurelius to liberation
theology well liberation theology at the
it's a Catholic kind of a Catholic
theology of social justice and it has it
had its stronghold and beginning in
Central America but I mean I think it is
just one of the things about being a
grounded theory researcher that I love
and hate is we don't start with an
existing theory and then go try to prove
or disprove it we build a theory from
people's lived experiences and then we
do the literature review and see where
it fits and where it doesn't fit because
it's the idea between behind grounded
theory is if you start with a an
existing theory you're just kind of
paying homage to they would say the
theoretical capitalist that came before
you and then it's people's lived
experiences that really matter instead
people often comment in my books they're
like how is it that you're quoting I do
quote Marcus Aurelius I think in one of
my books how are you quoting him and
then how are you quoting Pema Chodron
who's an American Buddhist nun
you're quoting Disney adding a Pixar
movie from Toy Story and to me I have no
division and very little tolerance for
like the highbrow versus lowbrow
inspiration I think if you're paying
attention you can find truth and
inspiration anywhere and everywhere and
so to me I'm all over the place in the
literature and I think the people who
really depend on polarity will hate this
but really some very strong common
themes across Christianity Buddhism
Judaism let me know Islam
Joseph Campbell I mean I think I end up
finding myself in some just profound
truths from a lot of I mean I was
reading something yesterday in the data
and it made me pull out my book by Quran
so I think it's roomy Marielle Mary
Oliver Neil Peart the drummer for rush
like I was something came up and I was
like yeah I was like I didn't know if
you knew so I had to put it in there but
um I was like this is when you cheat
when you cheat when you don't make a
choice when you choose not to decide you
still have made a choice and I think I
don't know that anyone says it more
eloquently than Rush
you know I'll just say Neil yeah just as
a side note if people want to see just a
beast of a drummer then you can you can
search on youtube for some videos this
guy oh my goodness what a just monster
on the kit but an appellate you know so
I find my inspiration kind of everywhere
and let's let's talk about
misinterpretations of vulnerability for
a second and I think maybe I'm getting a
little I'm probably projecting my own
prejudices here but is it vulnerability
there I think there are some people who
misinterpret being vulnerable and the
benefits derived from
vulnerable with incessant over sharing
of emotions or our inner dialogue or
doubt what would you say to this what
would you say to those people
maybe my diagnosis is off off-base but
there's some there are a lot of people
who just kind of pour out every concern
worried fault mistake and and okay it
with the the label of vulnerability so I
just love to hear your thoughts on that
word sound that I just dropped on you I
love it and I'm tracking 100% because I
yet it's you know there's a very simple
formula in my head vulnerability -
boundaries is not vulnerability it can
be desperation it can be oversharing it
can be manipulation it can be a lot of
different things but it's not
vulnerability we always have to hold
awareness of boundaries and roles in our
minds around vulnerability we share with
people who earn the right to hear our
story and we stay mindful all the time
of the rule we're at and so one of the
great examples I can give you is I'm
with 50 CEOs from Silicon Valley and we
spent a long weekend together and toward
the end of maybe the first day one of
them says I came here thinking that I
would never you know believe in
vulnerability are accepted but I am a
hundred percent on board so I want to
make sure I understand that I should
stand up in front of you know my
investors my VCS you know and say look I
am in over my head
we are bleeding money and I do not know
what to do next right and I said you
know only if you don't want another
round of funding should you do that I
mean no that's that's super and it's not
appropriate but let me you know let me
ask you this if you had you know if you
had I don't know fifty thousand dollars
invested with this leader
wouldn't you be praying to God that he's
sitting across from someone saying that
sure definitely right right I don't care
if it's whether it's his therapist a
mentor an adviser because what the would
the alternative is if he's really
drowning in over his head and bleeding
money and doesn't know what he's doing
is to just keep grinding harder and
harder on the same things he's doing and
not ask for help
right right totally good yeah and so
when people say you know live-tweeting
your bikini wax
that is not vulnerability sorry about
that it was only once yeah I mean if so
if you could hold back all that Tim we'd
really all appreciate it now are sharing
intimate details of your children's
reaction to your impending divorce on
Facebook that is not vulnerability
vulnerability is the birthplace of
intimacy trust connection creativity
innovation for leaders it's the
birthplace of trusted influence but it's
not permission to overshare right right
well I mean the thought the investor
example is great because the if a if a
CEO or founder gets up and says it
provides the confession that you gave us
an example in front of a room that will
almost inevitably respond by say yanking
funding it's not a it's not a
constructive use of that confession if
that makes sense and it's I live in San
Francisco most of the time and it's it's
this this sort of just this
misinterpretation of vulnerability as
oversharing is very common among the
kind of Burning Man spiritual atheist
sect and it's I think it's massively
problematic I think it creates its it
appears to create many more problems
than it solves and let me use that as a
segue to the the opposite I was
interviewing a
strength coach named Pavel taught suelen
is originally from I think the run the
Ukraine in any case former Soviet Union
and I one of the questions I asked him
on the podcast was what in your book
what do you write in your personal
journal that you don't often talk about
with other people and his head sir was
well Tim that is a very personal
question
and he proceeded to double and he
proceeded to tell me that you know
oversharing is is a big problem in the
United States and I was like well you
know that's actually I feel like that's
a fair response and so I wanted to ask
you a question that's based on input
from a number of listeners of this
podcast and the here's the lead and I'd
be very curious to hear your thoughts so
there's lots of chatter about over
feminization of boys how do you how do
you how do you have vulnerability
coexist with strong masculine virtues /
traits and I'm paraphrasing here and
I'll just give another sort of
contextual example that may or it may or
may not be interesting to comment on so
there's an expression in some military
training that is suffer in silence and
the idea is if you're going through hell
week for the Navy SEALs or something
like that and you're carrying logs
around and laying down in the freezing
cold water climbing under barbed wire
doing all these just nausea and fear
inducing things if you complain like my
foot hurts this that and the other thing
it will trigger more suffering in the
people around you which I happen to
agree with in that context so that's a
lot at once but but what what is your
thinking on the the the so called sort
of over feminization of boys and
masculine virtues / traits vs.
vulnerability I mean how do they coexist
and maybe that's not even the right
question it's a really good question and
I you know I work a lot with special
forces and with the military and and
with that may add one more thing just
yeah just so that I'm I'm not I people
don't think I'm representing only the
male side of this yeah a lot of my
female friends complain to me that in a
lot of urban centers in the u.s. San
Francisco etc they can only find guys to
date and they're looking for men to date
so it's not just this is this is a
concern not just from the male side it
seems to be coming from both sides so
sorry to interrupt but I just wanted to
throw yeah I think it's really important
so I have so much to say on it that
overwhelmed I kind of know where to
start so I'm gonna just try to I am just
like busting a gut over here okay hey so
these binaries of you know tough and
tender masculine feminine you know I
think we have to be really careful about
this because if we when we start to talk
about votes to talk about and in the
context of my work you gotten really
really wrong I'm like yeah okay if you
talk about vulnerability and
vulnerability to me is courage and so
when I when I hear women talk about
their inability to be with a vulnerable
man it makes tons of sense to me because
you know you know I wish I could say you
know at the number one perpetrator of
shame with men we're all those you know
shitty dads and terrible coaches and
those buddies but the number one
perpetrator of shame with men is women
and so I often say show me a woman who
can sit with a man in real fear and
vulnerability
I will show you a woman who's done her
own work around vulnerability and
doesn't derive her power or status from
that man you show me a man who can sit
with a woman who's in real fear and
vulnerability and I'll show you a man
who's done his own work around
vulnerability and doesn't derive his
power from being oz the all knowing and
all fixing because what men have a
tendency to do when we're feeling
vulnerable are afraid is trying to fix
it because it's how we're socialized and
so I don't think when you talk about how
we're raising boys today here's what I
can tell you from 150,000 pieces of data
looking back from what I've learned from
men the men who were raised to be open
and feeling and tender and loving and
given no skills and no information on
how to navigate boy culture and male
culture do not do well right the boys
who were raised on how to navigate male
culture king of the hill it had no tools
on how to be open and vulnerable and
emotionally available do worse but they
also don't do well so it's about we need
to stop with these false separations
between tough and tender you know tough
and tender can coexist and to me that's
kind of this that's kind of the equation
for badassery and it can also exist in
women like you know grit and grace tough
and tender afraid and brave you know
this idea that we're either courageous
or [ __ ] is just not true because
most of us are afraid and braid at the
exact same moment all day long
and so to take courage and vulnerability
to take to not teach that to our kids
or girls is not teaching them how to be
emotionally available or tender either
right and so I think what concerns me is
about the need to drive a stake through
the middle of these things um and I
think that's what's really important I
mean to be both ya know and I agree with
you I mean I think that they're not
actually exclusive there's no need for a
false dichotomy it's I think a lot of it
comes back to sort of choosing the
appropriate environment for expressing
that vulnerability if that makes sense
it's it's a toughy it seems it seems
tough I mean I because you find men who
have the armor plating on and can never
take it off that for what it's worth the
guys I've met who are operating at the
highest level and say Special Forces do
not have that problem they are they tend
not to suffer from a lot of PTSD for
instance and they are very empathetic
and emotionally a tune for the at least
in the subset of folks that I've met but
they've they've been subjected to just
insane amounts of abuse and conditioning
to for mental and physical toughness but
at the same time I see them playing with
their kids or with their wives and
they're extremely present so that's but
that's it's a tough needle to thread a
suit company so speaking of just the
challenges that people have with save
vulnerability what are some daily
practices or exercises that people can
can test to help them develop more
vulnerability less shame etc you know I
think it's interesting that you talk
about you know daily practices because I
think vulnerability is a daily practice
and for a lot of us you know at least
for me when it when it was new it was
about trying on new ways of being and
kind of testing it out one of the things
that emerged from the data is this this
idea of trust and
relationship between trust and
vulnerability and people always ask me
you gain trust first and then you're
vulnerable with people but the truth is
you can't really earn trust over time
with people without being somewhat
vulnerable so it's a little bit of a
back-and-forth it's a little bit of
sharing things that are maybe not super
deeply personal but are meaningful to
you and seeing how that feels to share
them and be open one thing that you said
that I've never thought about until this
interview but it was such a remarkable
insight from you but I want to go back
to when you talk about daily practice is
when you were talking about
perfectionism being future-focused
and also kind of presenting some
struggles about staying in the now I
think that's why and again I'm just
putting this insight together your
insight I think that's why a lot of
people who are that super uber
competitive high strong overachieving
don't get the same results in their
personal lives with their partners and
their children as they do in their
professional kind of endeavors or their
recreational endeavors because our
personal relationships with the people
we love those intimate relationships
require a presence a focus on now
that a lot of times professional success
does not depend on that as much very
true yeah very true
you can fly fast and if you know if
you're in a little Cessna two-seater you
got a you know you're in the here and
now and you got to pay attention to
every bump and every gauge and paint you
know but if you're in a jet you can't
afford to be thinking about now you have
to be thinking about five minutes from
now
and so I thought it was a really
remarkable and set on your part because
when I do think about those 10 friends
in Silicon Valley or I think about my
own life even I think what the research
has changed most is that I think it has
had a huge and
I've done my professional success but
more than anything when I get home I
walk into a marriage enter a
relationship with kids that is fun
they're fundamentally different than
they were before I became okay with
vulnerability and ok with
less-than-perfect what what is the first
60 to 90 days of up 60 90 days 60 to 90
minutes of your day look like your
morning routines or rituals outside of
book launch times and things like that
let's just assume that you have control
of your your optimal day but what's the
first what are your morning rituals look
like what is your first 60 to 90 minutes
look like I wake up um what I'm doing
6:30 ish I wake up I do a lot of deep
breathing to stay off an absolute
desperate need for a hit of data um from
my phone or from my computer so I try
very hard not to check email or text
because I don't I sleep with my phone
downstairs I don't sleep with any kind
of computer next to me and then you know
it's really super normal I wake up kids
I make breakfast I pack lunches I go
through the calendar of the day I zip up
backpacks I Drive carpool I usually get
from carpool to swim I'm a swimmer a
competitive swimmer so I like to swim
and I swim and walk um swimming is kind
of the trifecta for me it's not
imitation exercise and therapy and then
I usually start my day my work day at
what time what time what time do you
finish swimming and how long is the swim
session and I run my best case scenarios
I run and swim and so I don't swim fast
enough anymore I don't swim time time
swim anymore like you know 50s on every
20 or anything like I used to so it's
more it's not as cardio as it used to be
so I like to run on the treadmill for 30
minutes and then I like to swim for half
an hour
got it and if I was a bike rider I could
be a triathlete
the fact that I tried it once and the
bike going that fast
next to that many people going that fast
is really uncomfortable for me
yeah I'd imagine it so I'm at a plate um
what what book besides your own have you
gifted to other people most but where
what book do you have you often given as
a gift oh man I have given so many
copies of The Alchemist to people that I
should get a little royalty on it yeah
that's a great book that's a great book
speaking of books so you have a new book
out rising strong and it seems to me
like this completes a trilogy in a sense
it seems like the three books go
together very well but could you give
people a description of the latest book
and why you wrote it yeah sure and I
think they do go together and I I wasn't
intentional on that but I think the
gifts is bu daring greatly is B all N
and this book is get your ass kicked get
up and do it again this is about just
the physics of vulnerability you know if
you're brave enough often enough you're
going to fall you're going to experience
heartbreak disappointment failure it's
going to happen and so going into this
research the question for me was what do
men and women who experience Falls and
get back up and are even more courageous
and more tenacious what do they have in
common so rising strong is about the
process that emerged from that question
and can you describe your your research
method how do you find your interviewees
what is the sort of interview format
look like what do you do with the data
afterwards etc about 70% of my
interviews are individuals and more
focus groups in the last data set and so
some of them looks for example I went to
West Point and sat down with
if I think there were six officers who
had all come back from active combat
duty so sometimes I'll do focus groups
and but the majority of them are
individuals a lot of it is snowball
sampling meaning I've interviewed you
Tim and I'm like you know what unreal
this is really helpful
I would love to interview some of the
folks that you know in Silicon Valley
around perfectionism would you mind
doing a warm introduction right and some
of them are just kind of calls like this
this book is a lot about the power of
story and the stories we tell ourselves
so I introduced Shonda Rhimes the
showrunner for scandal and and so
sesamum are just you know it's a lot
easier to get people now than it was
when I first started and I was like hi
my name is per day and I would like to
talk to you about shame but now it's
more that you know I can now I just do
mostly individual in focus groups and so
then I get the data I hey we don't
record it I take what we call in the
field anthropological field notes so I
capture exact phrases and sentences
during our interview I let participants
look at them if they want to when
they're done some say yes some say no
and then I code what I learned against
what I already know that were patterns
and saturation and the data meaning if I
am trying to study perfectionism and
entrepreneurs in Silicon Valley
I'll start interviewing them and I'll
know that I've reached saturation when I
can predict what the next person is
going to say because one of the really
tough rules of grounded theory research
are we don't allow for any outliers and
so if I'm almost done and then I sit
down with you and you say something and
doesn't fit with the theory that I'm
developing in my head about what's
happening then I have to go back to the
drawing board and keep interviewing
because every lived experience is real
and matters right so it would be like
interviewing a hundred people in Silicon
Valley or saying they're trying to
democratize Pizza ordering democratize
kitty-litter delivery democratize this
and then someone said I'm really looking
to
a silo of command and control like a
North Korean dictator 4x anybody alright
then I have to keep going if that
happened then I have to question what
I'm hearing I have to question what I'm
hearing from the kitty litterer and the
other folks right and I have to figure
out what what do y'all meaning what do
y'all meaningfully say in Kok have in
common and it means it seems to me
rising strong is it's a must have not a
nice-to-have
right and I'm not saying that the be
yourself dare greatly are nice-to-haves
but if you don't have the resilience to
recover from mistakes you're never going
to dare greatly in the first place in
some respect it would seem right so if
you if would you recommend what order
would you recommend people read your
books in I mean understanding that this
is the the latest of course but what's
sort of a the ideal sequence yeah I
think you know they go together but they
don't mean I think they can each be read
independently so I think sometimes it's
helpful to pick up the book based on
where you are if you're really
struggling with the hustle with hustling
for perfection and hustle any improving
and perfecting and pretending I think
the gifts is great if you really are you
know like the rest of us sick and tired
of being afraid and you want to be brave
and you want to feel like what does that
look like I think during great Leigh's
is this place to start and if you find
yourself face down in the arena and
you're thinking god I just got my ass
handed to me
I think I'm rising strong would be a
good place to start it probably makes
sense you know there's a sequence so I
think if you're just like mom I'm
interested I would start with dear and
great I mean uh the gifts but I think I
also think for your audience it's
probably helpful to know that I spent
the last couple of years probably
exclusively working with leaders and
entrepreneurs so daring greatly and
rising strong have much more of my
research from organizations and from
leaders than the gifts des got it know
that is helpful
just a few more questions and then I'm
sure coming up on time so that's just a
couple of rapid for our questions but
the answers don't have to be rapid and
I'm I'm very curious about this one when
you think of the word successful who is
the first person who comes to mind for
you and why you know what's so weird I
don't picture anybody I picture the word
redefine that that is such a that has
been such a dangerous word in my
research the word successful yeah our
success I agree that I don't even use it
anymore because what does that mean like
okay so I am the CEO this company I make
a [ __ ] ton of money this is my title
this is the influence and power I have
I'm on my fourth marriage and no
relationship with my adult children
right so I I think when I hear the word
successful my answer is be clear that
your ladder is leaning against the right
building right yeah bad word next
question yeah I don't know why I don't
know I I agree with you I think
happiness is actually right similar in
ours
yes that's a scary nebulous dangerous
term as well so uh what $100 or less
purchase has most positively impacted
your life in recent memory Oh
triathlon goggles because I don't know
for some reason they're softer um so
that I don't have goggle marks all day
oh really I had no idea what what do you
know the brand of goggles offhand yeah
but they're like the most famous
triathlon but and they're really Patty
and you look like we all like swam with
the speedo Vanquisher like little
goggles that looks for a badass and the
bigger your goggle the goofier you were
but now it's time for the goofy goggle
for me yeah I really like the Aqua
Sphere Cayman goggles ka i MA and and
Laird Hamilton is this big wave surfer
yeah uses
I will look them up goggles I just put
them for those people interested it put
them in my latest five bullet Friday you
can just search my name five bullet
Fridays but yeah it does seem like the
bigger goggles coming back uh if if you
could have one billboard anywhere with
anything on it what would it say and
where would you put it I would put it in
Washington DC and it would say shut up
and listen that's great that's great
that that could be put anywhere I would
love to put that on on the highway you
know highway 101 at 218 Silicon Valley -
cuz man oh man are people talking a lot
these days
pitching pitching really hard without
asking many good questions you know I
wouldn't say shut up because my kids
would be like oh my god we're not even
allowed to say that word so I would say
talk less listen more but I would in my
heart I would saying shut up yeah we
could split test it could it could be
that it that could be the hashtag yeah
just shut your face uh what advice would
you give your thirty year old self it's
okay to be afraid
you don't have to be so scary when
you're scared huh meaning what put on
put on airs of confidence and overcome
yes yes like the 30s are so exhausting
it's like the aah yeah it is at the age
of perfecting proving pretending and
there's some liberation that can't you
know for me that came in my for there's
a breakdown of course that followed lots
of liberation that came in my 40s so I
would just say you know every now stop
hustling right
yeah the mentioned the break down the
the break through disguises to break
down uh what did you say to your 30 year
old self start meditating and chilled
[ __ ] out that's you don't need to you
don't need to have a resting pulse of
150 beats per minute to get a lot of big
things done there's similar messages
right yeah very similar I think that
well I think it's very easy for people
and I'm sure I still do this but to
mistake the symptoms of success with the
things that cause success they're not
the same right do you have any ask or
requests for all the people listening of
course I would highly recommend that
they check out your work including
rising strong the latest book which I
will link to in the show notes for
everybody but any other ask request or
recommendation for everybody listening I
would just say keep being part of the
conversation about these tougher about
these temper topics about vulnerability
about shame about being brave just lean
into some discomfort because I think
these what's the seemingly impossible
problems that we have around race and
homophobia and the environment and just
the lack of love sometimes are not going
to be solved in a comfortable way we
can't we've got it you know you have to
choose comfort or courage you just can't
have those
so I guess my ask would be more of a big
metaphysical ask that give vulnerability
a shot you know and give discomfort its
do because I think there is a really
strong relationship between your
willingness he or she who's willing to
be the most uncomfortable is not only
the bravest that rises the fastest
totally agree well I think the the only
the only way to ensure long term comfort
is to have continual short-term
discomfort
how's that well this has been a blast
burn eh where can people say hello to
you online where can they find out more
about you find you on the the social
networks yeah and I am at an at brené
Brown on Twitter and Instagram and burn
a brown on Facebook we just launched a
new project that we're excited about
called courage works and which is
bringing all of my teachings to online
for individuals and leaders and
organizations and that's just courage
works calm and so on it I'm in all those
places well I enjoy your work I
appreciate your work and thank you so
much for taking the time folks listening
you can find links to everything that we
discussed show notes etc at four-hour
work week calm and just click on podcast
all spelled out for our work week calm
and please say hello to burn a on the
interwebs and join the conversation I'll
also have a question of the day in the
blog post that you guys can continue
this conversation as Brene suggested but
Rene thank you so much for making the
time it was awesome thank you so much
Tim I appreciate it and everybody
listening as always thank you for
listening and until next day until next
day until next time Tim needs more
caffeine Buddha Buddha and face your
discomfort practice discomfort thanks
for listening
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in wealth
run so the question is why why is it so
popular why is it unique because you can
get services previously reserved for the
ultra wealthy but only pay pennies on
the dollar for them and this is because
they use smarter software instead of
retail locations bloated sales teams etc
and I'll come back to that in a second I
suggest you check out wealthfront
dot-com forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz which only takes two to
five minutes and they'll show you for
free exactly the portfolio they put you
in and if you just want to take their
advice run with it do it yourself you
can do that or as I would you can set it
and forget it here's why the value of
wealth front is in the automation of
habits and strategies that investors
should be using on a regular basis but
normally aren't great investing is a
marathon not a sprint and little things
that you may or may not be familiar with
like automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than 10 asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealth front as I mentioned since
it's using software instead of retail
locations etc can offer all of this at
low costs that were previously
completely impossible right off the bat
you never pay commissions or account
fees for everything they charge 0.25
percent per year on assets above the
first 15,000 which is managed for free
if you use my link wealthfront com
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on the
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been
so impressed by wealthfront that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss show listener you'll get fifteen
thousand dollars managed for free if you
decide to open an account but just start
with seeing the portfolio that they
would suggest for you take two minutes
fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront comm forward slash Tim it's
fast free there's no downside that I can
think of now I do have to read a
mandatory disclaimer wealthfront
Inc is an SEC registered investment
advisor investing in securities involves
risks and there's the possibility of
losing money past performance is no
guarantee of future results please visit
wealthfront comm to read their full
disclosure so check it out guys this is
one of the hottest most innovative
companies coming out of Silicon Valley
and they're killing it
they've become massively popular just
take a look see what portfolio they
would create for you and you can use
that information however you want
wealthfront comm forward slash Tim this
episode is brought to you by Vimeo Pro
which is the ideal video hosting
platform for entrepreneurs and in fact a
bunch of my startups already use Vimeo
Pro including wealthfront
who uses it to explain how wealthfront
works TaskRabbit uses it to tell their
company's story and there are many other
names you would recognize among their
customers Airbnb Etsy etc why do they
use it well Vimeo Pro provides
enterprise level video hosting for a
fraction of the usual cost features
include gorgeous high quality playback
with no ads up to 20 gigabytes of video
storage every week
unlimited plays and views and a fully
customizable video player which can
include your logo custom outro etc you
also get VIP support and you get all of
this for just $1.99 per year that's $17
a month with no complicated bandwidth
calculations or hidden fees and you can
try it risk-free for 30 days so check it
out Vimeo comm forward slash business
that's VI m EO com forward slash
business and use promo code Tim to get
25% off that's a special discount just
for you guys so check it out Vimeo com
forward slash business promo code Tim
and until next time thank you for
listening
you